our next intro is visual special visual
effects and to present that award mr.
Roy Schneider
Awards for special effects are not given
every year but this year the Academy
Board of Governors has voted to imagine
a fantastic city of the 23rd century a
futuristic utopia ecologically balanced
filled with unending pleasures absent of
individual responsibility and nurtured
by complete sexual freedom yes Newark
New Jersey
now the extraordinary City in Logan's
Run
and here are the men who worked the
miracles in the world of tomorrow Len
would be Abbot Matthew J URIs H and
Glenn Robinson the legends
I want to very sincerely thank the Board
of Directors of the Academy the producer
mr. Saul David and that great host of
wonderful helpers made this accolade
possible for me I'd like to thank Bill
average for 27 years of health and
guidance and to my fellow members of the
special effects committee for this honor
and especially to my wife Matilda
without whose fierce loyalty I couldn't
have gotten through these difficult
years without her I couldn't have gotten
very far and this is very very far and I
want to thank myself because I think I
earned
I wish to thank the Academy and also mr.
Saul David MGM studios and mysteries
well and Scarlatti and the great team of
special effects people that were with me
they do the job thank you
he stands 40 feet tall weighs six and a
half tons contains 3,100 feet of
hydraulic hose and 4,500 feet of
electric wiring he's covered with 4000
pounds of hair is terrifying when
aroused but has the soul of a romantic
lover Dino DiLaurentis the one and only
King Kong
the Academy honors the creators of this
sibian Colossus Carlo Rambaldi Frank van
Devere and again Glenn Robinson for pink
top
thank you for Academy thank you for Dino
De Laurentiis I taught them all speak
English who gave us opportunity Toto
read conch grazie
ladies and gentlemen this represents so
much effort on the part of so many
people I'm most grateful to them to King
Kong and you know for making this
possible
I thank them may God bless them and
thank you again I'm very thankful for
this privilege and I'm thankful to the
Academy and to mr. DiLaurentis who gave
us this privilege and the great gang
that put it together and took a lot of
facets in the special effects field and
we certainly appreciate the special
effects people that I thank you
thank you there's been a pleasure
hosting this segment of the show and
before I go I really like to say
something
hey everybody back in Peoria me